un homme sur cinq vivent en couple
aurait été victime de violences
conjugales pendant la pandémie ça c'est
selon les résultats d'une enquête qui a
été réalisée auprès de 10000 personnes
de ces 10000 y avait 4000 hommes par une
équipe qui est dirigé par la docteure
mélissa généreuse l'université de
sherbrooke mais pour en parler en juin
philippe roy il est professeur à l'école
de travail social de l'université de
sherbrooke mongeau monsieur roy
bonjour madame restait alors vous dites
qu'il est trop tôt pour interpréter les
résultats mais comment est-ce que vous
allez vous y prendrez ce que vous avez
déjà des hypothèses
on essaie de prendre notre temps quand
les questions d'interpréter ces
résultats la voyez on est d'avoir une
enquête à ma collègue c'est un savoir
scientifique comprend le temps de
croiser avec le savoir des
professionnels de l'intervention et
allez savoir expérience elle donc des
personnes qui ont suivi la violence
conjugale
donc sur le terrain par exemple les
organismes pour homme en estrie ont
partagé leurs préoccupations pour la
violence subie par les hommes qui
consultent et c'est cette préoccupation
qui trouve écho dans les résultats de l'
enquête alors oui on essaye de croiser
les données de médecins en perspective
où c'est avec notre sondage sur santé
bien-être des hommes durant la pandémie
alors c'est une démarche qui prend du
temps on essaye
d'éviter de tomber dans des débats
idéologiques
le but c'est pas d'alimenter une
quelconque guerre des sexes on est
beaucoup appelaient questionner nos
billets pour adopter une vision plus
inclusive de toutes les personnes qui se
disent la violence conjugale dans le
comté de la pandémie dû reconnaître
leurs besoins
votre étude dit que les plus touchés ce
sont les jeunes hommes c'est-à-dire
entre 18 et 24 ans est-ce que c'est
étonnant où vous vous dites ils sont
tellement jeune et ouvert à parler de ça
que ça me surprend pas
résultat cette enquête à plusieurs
égards dont beaucoup mettre au défi nos
perceptions d'une vaillance n'oubliez
donc oui et non en fait parce que on
pense que les jeunes sont plus ouverts
plus égalitaire mais il ya une
méta-analyse québécoise qui montre que
les jeunes hommes s'éloigne du modèle
traditionnel de maistre unités for
stoïque s'arrangent tous seuls agressif
c'est vrai que s'éloigne c'est vrai
qu'ils expriment davantage d'émotion à
leurs familles à leurs amis mais la
demande doit être auprès des
professionnels sur tout ce qui est parce
qu social c'est encore très difficile
est ce les mêmes difficultés que pour
les hommes de tout âge bon alors si il
en demande pas tant que ça de l'aide
est-ce qu'il y en a quand même des
ressources pour aider ces hommes là
tout à fait oui alors dans toutes les
régions du québec la ligne info social 8
en 1 puis des ressources communautaires
pour hommes partout au québec ont fait
un modèle d'exception le québec dans le
canada et à l'international
un des défis je parlais des billets mais
c'est de reconnaître les liens entre la
détresse psychologique et la possible
qui est violence conjugale subie par les
hommes parce que ça on a une conception
oui les hommes ne peuvent pas être
victimes et faut surmonter donc les
intervenants internes en première ligne
doivent surmonter leurs propres billets
leur proposant convaincre la clientèle
masculine
suffit qu'on fait notamment que la
formation intervenir auprès des hommes
qui rejoint des milliers d'intervenants
tels intervenants de la première ligne
donc oui il ya des ressources il ya des
gens qui sont qualifiés pour accueillir
cette situation là non justement vous
parlez de méconnaissance par rapport à
ça mais il ya aussi une banalisation de
la violence conjugale en tout cas en ce
qui touche les hommes il ça doit bien
avoir des impacts sur des conséquences
qu'on banalise ce phénomène de
la violence est souffrante la
banalisation elle est aussi visée se
sait des choses qu'on a entendues pour
plusieurs formes de souffrance au
plusieurs formes de trauma
donc louis une banalisation et elle est
beaucoup plus large que la violence
conjugale elle est là pour santé
bien-être des hommes donc les hommes ont
de la difficulté à percevoir qu'une
situation est problématique a décidé
vers qui se tourner et passer à l'action
d'aller d'aller demander de l'aide et là
dessus une des meilleures
représentations que j'ai eu c'est la
publicité de la mycose des ongles ou
est-ce que le goy totalement dans le
tennis etc c'est vrai pour l'exemple qui
a été dans la publicité mais c'est vrai
aussi pour la santé puisque léger que
c'est vraiment évocateur le fait de nier
des à savoir s'en aller tout seul ça va
s'arranger seule série gagne donc un
billet optimiste un peu que les maisons
doit être plus alertes de voir mon dieu
mais ce que je vis et de la violence et
où il ya des gens qui peut m'aider que
je n'ai pas vivre ça et comme en voit
pas de
l'équivalent des féminicides mais
peut-être qu'effectivement on reconnaît
pas la même les mêmes impacts pour les
hommes
on reconnaît pas les mêmes impacts qu'il
faut lutter je pense toutes les formes
de violences et être solidaire là dessus
maintenant il ya une et pas que chez les
hommes qui étaient mesurées par exemple
ceux qui vivent la dette la violence
conjugale sont trois fois plus à risque
de dépression du ministère et dans une
moindre mesure une augmentation il ya
une augmentation de l'anxiété de la
consommation d'alcool donc ça n'est pas
sans conséquence ça c'est certain merci
infiniment philippe roy nous avoir parlé
aujourd'hui
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
[Musique]